do i have a social media manager i do
not
i do all my yeah i do all the thumbnails
and titles on my own
yeah i used to do like small photoshop
gigs so
it's fun sometimes to just do do these
crazy thumbnails for youtube
oh chess time please well if you say
please
and write in all caps i don't actually
support all cap's messages but i do
support the word saying please or the
word please
so i think what i'll do is i'll start
with a longer
time control and then maybe work my way
to blitz
and maybe if i get really tilted i'll
work my way to bullets
we'll see okay so i'm playing omar assad
or no if you take away some of the
letters it will be omar saj
let's play i'll play my main stuff
oh thanks chat for being
being
would you call someone who just says
please
begging oh thanks shot for begging
okay um
are you using the magic word okay so
we're gonna have
maybe a standard i'm gonna play iphone's
not gonna fall into it but i'm gonna
play this just for fun
it's called the elephant trap it looks
like white could take the pawn but
white's not going for it
i'll show it after the game
i wanted to play cambridge springs but
queen a5 doesn't really make much sense
when i don't have the possibility of
opening the the fifth rank so i'll just
be solid
thanks for the great for castling oh
thanks for subbing
every time edom i think that's the first
sub of the stream
i do appreciate the people who subbed
during my tennis stream
uh play rookie one
do i have to worry about this move i
don't think so
if it happens it happens hey it's
bicycle
oh you're in the dc area oh wow on
standby
worked five 12-hour days
oh man well i hope i can relieve the
stress a little bit
i'll try and keep this stream um
low low stress and high chest
oh good to have you back thank you jim
the frogs and ron the
runner or ron the drummer
i can't read okay um
i think we're still in my prep actually
i'm taking so much time but
um the idea here is actually a very
specific idea
to play knight g6 first taking away
these squares from the bishop
the whole goal is to get the bishop pair
and to get some king-side attack
okay white wants to minority attack this
is very normal
um yeah this is all still prep so i play
bishop here
walking into a pin but with the idea of
playing h6
forcing white to take and then i'll
activate the queen
um yeah this is all still prep
that's funny i took so much time in the
beginning like trying to figure out the
move order
but uh it's actually a cool line
i have probably five maybe five more
moves of preparation
the critical line is uh takes takes in
e4
actually takes takes takes takes e4
and then there's a cool move which i
think up until recently was a novelty
but i discovered this line maybe two or
three
no i discovered this line maybe 2015.
i very remember very vividly remember
showing this line
to susan polgar when i first attended
webster university and she wasn't so
impressed
um because it was a little bit like
offbeat
but it's it's engine approved
so stockfish was impressed
but we're only like scratching the
surface there's another move here for
like bishop takes g6
okay so we're not going to get like the
cool variation i'll show it afterwards
so
uh best move is to take here and this is
actually a pleasant position
uh because now i have h file and i have
g4
i want to play g4 so soon i mean the
pawns hanging
a common idea here is g6 king g7 rook h8
i'm realizing white can't why it's not
threatening to take because i take on h2
and
knight g4 and win the knight
if i play g6 too soon there's this move
maybe it's a little bit murky
so i think i will play g4
kick the knights i mean white's trying
to play positioning on the queen side
i want to play aggressively on the king
side
now might be the time to play g6
because now if white sucks uh it's only
the queen
i have king h8 queen h6 and
[Music]
and the pawns defended let's do it
yeah the whole idea is to use h file
okay let's take also thanks for subbing
haberino 69 something with prime
and also two for 17 subbing with prime
for two months
in gerardo underscore mr
new sub at tier one
oh and jim the frog or jim the frog e
thanks for subbing for three months
so it's a fun position like there's some
risk because this pawn's weak
and kind of backwards um
but it's the type of position i'm happy
with
uh from a queen's gambit decline where
there's a lot of
attacking potential and most of white's
pieces are on the queen side
not helping defend the king so it's
usually a sign to attack but okay
white's trying to attack me
so i was kind of expecting this or at
least aware of this
now the strategy might change
a little bit wow e4
e4
so it's writing e5
which would be very unpleasant i always
want to take a
a look at each two
[Music]
also the queen
i mean i should consider just taking
the problem is if i take twice and
there's the very least perpetual for
white
which i probably don't want to allow
there's bishop f4 which is kind of neat
because i would cover h6 and i attack
the knight
which is defending the pawn this might
be the most like forcing approach
bishop f4 e5 whoa it's a raid
it's cuba law thanks for raiding with 50
people
appreciate that if you're just joining
i'm in the midst of trying to figure out
what to do with my life my position is
very complex white
destroyed my king side but i have an
extra minor piece
um if a mod can give a shout out to
kubala that would be appreciated
so bishop f4 let's imagine bishop f4
i mean e5 still possible but then maybe
i can play rook g8
forcing the trade of queens and then i
take the knight and then there's pawns
weak
and i have the bishop hair
let's do it
i like this move because it's it's
defending but it's also attacking
in the one danger the bishop's not
defended so have to be aware of
potential tactics but
covering a lot of squares here the
knight and bishop combine well
along with other bishop ii i'm
controlling almost all the squares
around the queen
and this is almost trapping the queen
actually i think it is this is a big
threat
because rook g8 queen f7 i have rook g7
and the queen's completely trapped
but now okay now the queen wants to take
but this uh yeah this is what i
calculated to play rook g8
queen f6 we trade and then i win the
knight
and then my king's super safe after the
queen trade
and the position simplifies a bit
white doesn't really have any other
option
[Music]
let's do it
i guess there's queen f7 here
which is actually a little bit confusing
um i'll have options after queen f7
actually queen f7 i take the knight and
i'm threatening the other night
oh there's still i have to be careful
what i say because my opponent might be
watching
oh i love you too thanks for flushing
or blushing blushing no it says flushed
is that a typo it's an emoji
wait is blood are blush and flush
the same thing i don't know
white's debating between these two moves
so i'll say what i'm well i was just
calculating
oh wait the queen can move this way what
i forgot the queen can move backwards
man
oh that existed in the other position
too
yeah queen f7 was not forced um
oh it didn't exist because the pawn was
here
but okay pawn moved wait bishop a6 is
just a tactic
bishop a6 winning material
i guess there's queen a full queen of
five
have to be on the lookout for squares
the queen f5 i take the knight
i think it's okay
can't move too slowly oh queen f5 i have
no rook g5
okay i see what to do bishop a6 if queen
i5 i take the knight
uh i was trying to figure out after pawn
takes knight white would be threatening
me just watch the video of you and tatef
very impressed with both of you
oh thanks so much i appreciate that atc
fast
yeah i might end up putting that to
youtube it was like a fun
it was like different type of content
like seriously studying
or seriously solving puzzles for for
about three hours
so i was just saying uh white
threatening mate
basically made in two um but i have rook
g5 here
bishop defends the rook i'm not getting
mated
and the queen the knight and the rook
are all attacked
so i'd better be winning something i
mean white's gonna go for
like crazy something
crazy something white wants to play f7
probably
but that doesn't scare me
um and the bishop is nice here stopping
rook b7
so let's take the knight up two bishops
what else hey it's targy what's up doggy
thanks for the bits oh tagi
said was it today or tomorrow that's
supposed to be special
i forget tagi was being
uh being
[Music]
informational the previous stream but i
forgot all the information
so now i can take
i mean there's going to be some small
headache it shouldn't be a
big issue
i'm up to bishops
well i might do actually i might just go
for
total simplification
[Music]
i should start by taking rook is going
to take here
i kind of want to play bishop d3
because the bishop helps attack and
defend but then
it's still a little bit murky
so my thought for total simplification
is after takes i have queen f6
and then
um i'll just be up a bishop for a pawn
in the end game
that's the nice thing about being up two
bishops
is sometimes you can sacrifice one of
them
and you're still up one bishop
it's nice how math works
so the one concern is i only have two
pawns
and to win this sort of position i need
to basically queen upon
nice thing is this pawn is passed
it can be supported for example after
takes
takes takes i have bishop c4
i can't draw arrows i even have d4d3
so as long as the rooks don't like
coordinate in perpetual or
check made by king um
it shouldn't be too
[Music]
too dangerous
so there's also this move um but then i
take the queen and then i'll be left
with the dark sword bishop
bishop can sit happily here and then
i'll push d4
wow
wow fancy move
what does this move so i think i'm i
should probably
take and then
okay i should just take first and then
think
i'm thinking rook h5
rook h5 stopping rook h6 and threatening
threatening a nice mating idea
oh there's a cool line uh rook
rook h5 rook g6 wait a minute
oh no rook h5 queen g4
wait this is complicated i gotta start
with rook h5 though
so i'm covering all directions to my
king i'm covering the file
the diagonal and the rank so
my king can effectively be checked
oh wait what was i thinking
wait this is complicated
[Music]
i want to play rook g8 but then i lose a
rook i have to play bishop e2 maybe
bishop b2 we trade i have bishop g7 in
the end it should still be okay
don't want to flag
now this bishop's playing a role and
there's mating ideas with like taking in
queen h4
for example if the queen moves here then
i i made in two
um i think this is yeah that's a
critical move
and white should run out of checks
because rook b7
i'll play this and i'm up two bishops
i guess there's there's queen c2 random
check
but i'm i have enough i don't have pawns
to shelter my king but i have a bishop
and a rook
and maybe even my queen
i'm still threatening maiden two as well
yeah i think um
if queen c2 check i block with the rook
g4 is never scary because i mate like
this
and then the rook here might help with
back rank mating ideas
yeah it's a weirdly like open position
all my pieces are like ready to attack
uh just have to to deal with my king
but i think my opponent is realizing uh
the doom
oh i'm not threatening this because uh
that's not mating because the queen has
h3
so what's my threat bishop here
i guess
this still takes a little bit of work
i'm threatening g2
how do i win i might just go for the
[Music]
simplification there's still no checks
at the very least i can go for the flag
but now i'm threatening mates we'll
trade queens
i really thought i would i would be
mating easily
but this will work yeah so now i'm
threatening this and this
the bishops are so nice together
okay i took work that was a cool game
hope people enjoy that thanks to the
the the subs epiphany 77. thanks for
subbing for 14 months
and thank you mr keflan gifting sub or
gifting a sub
oh gifting a tier 3 sub the very rare
tier 3 sub really appreciate that
gifting to y luminous
also thank you aspliz solving with prime
so
yeah i think like overall that was
actually a kind of
clean game i managed to
diffuse attack i like bishop f4
the sequence was nice there were a few
moves i missed from my opponent
like queen d3 i was i was blind the
queen could retreat
um but it worked out
so few things just to share in the
opening um
that might maybe some people will
appreciate
the first thing i was going for the the
elephant trap
i used to play this when i was really
young it was one of the first opening
traps i learned
and the point of 97 is you're allowing
white to take twice
on d5 looks like you just blundered the
pawn the knight's pinned
and your queen is not controlling d5
but the point is you can temporarily
give away your queen
and say oh no my queen and then you can
say
oh no white's queen
and you're you're winning a piece after
here take the queen take the bishop
and black is up in knight for a pawn so
it's a nice trap
i probably played this for the first
like two or three years of
my chest journey or longer
um a nice thing about this move is if
white plays like e3 or knight f3
you can still go for cambridge springs
which was like
what i was going for after c6 the main
move here is e3
and this is a cambridge springs um
i've shown this before on stream i
played a few games on this
which we're probably in probably on
youtube somewhere
uh the main trap here if white plays a
natural move bishop d3
then there's takes takes in this move
and black is forking
the bishop and the knight and it's
attacked twice by the
knighting queen
now i do have to show the line
i want to share my my secret preparation
um which i don't know if i've shown
before on stream actually
because we we went into a line which i
usually get
from a slightly different move order i
sometimes play a6 earlier but we would
still
kind of arrive at this position
and yeah the whole idea of bringing the
knight to g6 is to play bishop d6 and h6
which is what happened whoa it's gm
ashley
shout out to maurice yeah i saw marie
streaming earlier
really appreciate the raid grand master
maurice ashley everyone should follow
him on twitch
he has so much energy like all the time
he was also commentating right
the the recent uh puzzle competition
it was fun commentary hope you had a
good stream
if you're just joining i just played a
game in the queen's gambit declined
on my favorite openings for black
and i'm i'm about to share secret
preparation
which i didn't get in the game but
it's a cool line so i might as well
share it
and cheeto i'll address that in just a
moment
but okay so here my opponent took on g6
the main move if you look this up in the
database
um yeah it's natural for white to take
on f6
and then yeah usually white throws in
this move and then
um wait if we go to masters
yeah most played move in masters games
is e4
which actually looks a bit troublesome
for for white
because the queen and bishop are targets
uh e5 is a threat
if you take the knight takes and you get
fort
so there's a really cool idea here which
i discovered
i discovered like 2014 or 2015.
i've never actually had this position in
a tournament in a slow tournament i had
this once in a rapid tournament
in st louis and it was so nice just to
blitz out the next move
um so
i'm debating whether to give this as a
puzzle
but maybe i can i can let people think
find the move for black
i'm pretty sure we'll check um right
before i show it but i'm pretty sure
stockfish won't find the move
immediately
um and requires some depth to to fully
understand
so i already explained a little bit like
white wants to fork if you take
then knight takes so the move is not
taking
um that'll be my hint
fast move for black not taking the pawn
what to do
and thank you arch linux subbing with
prime
oh and chito is asking about the i am
not a gm
yeah i am excited i need to i need to
get better at chess
first my match was sagar so i'm playing
sagar's shot on the first round
um i think it's i think we're still
waiting for him to confirm
but the date i was told was january 28th
so i'll have a few weeks
okay people saying c5 queen f4 knight f4
a3 a3 f3
good job for no one saying king e2
usually there's at least one king e2
um yeah the beautiful thing about the
move is you are going to willingly get
forked like white's gonna you're gonna
allow e5
and it's all gonna be okay
oh there's some kiwi chews
okay so the move
oh your girlfriend doesn't have enough
channel points
but would like me to take a sip of tea
okay
rose i'm really happy that i can tune
into your stream and unwind after the
craziness of
today thanks for all of the great
content
oh my pleasure yeah streaming also helps
me unwind
it's nice to escape craziness once in a
while
appreciate that neiman marxist
okay so the the move is knight f4
it's a really cool idea um
allowing white to fork and then black
very calmly like doesn't do anything
like so crazy just yet
very commonly just moves the queen over
allows white to take the bishop and then
bam queen g4 and white's in some trouble
here like this is now objectively better
for black
and yeah we're just writing made in one
i'm pretty sure white only has
one move that doesn't lose immediately
which is 91. if white plays g3
then it should be forced mate after it
takes
takes in bishop h3 and white's pretty
much dead
so after knight e1 black is still now a
piece
is winning back the piece with this move
um rookie one
and the point is now we're again
threatening mate so i can't take back
the rook
uh white can survive here with f3
and now we take on f1 let's say
say bishop f1 and then we just move back
and we're going to win the pawn and
we'll be up a pawn
so that's my opening prep it
is 23 moves of of preparation
um that's a nice line
so maybe some queen's gambit declined
players will
will know what to do also tagi thanks so
much tagi
gifting five subs wow tagi's gifted 250
subs total
really appreciate that if this goes on
youtube
say hi to tagi yeah youtube comments are
usually pretty
pretty welcoming to tagi so i'll
probably put like the whole game and
some of this analysis on youtube
so i think this will be um valuable for
some people
so hope you enjoyed that if you're
watching on youtube thanks for watching
thanks for subscribing uh for all the
all you subscribers and thanks for
liking the video
and i'll see you in the future yeah
talking to the real mvp
maybe i'll have to play geo at some
point in the stream
just for tagi oh i was gonna check uh
stockfish
yeah um
remember when i was first using sockfish
to study this line
it was giving white an advantage until
knight f4 was played but let's see
maybe it knows by now so yeah it gives
white a small plus
um but maybe it's realizing we'll see
so h6 is this month the twitch baby
month
oh oh happy
baby month i guess thanks undivided
cloth becoming a baby
oh wait so bishop takes f6 takes
uh stockfish knows
so takes takes e4 and knight f4
i think the engines have gotten stronger
since when i first studied this line
i see so there's some other questions
too um maybe
about the actual game
so yeah this is actually like this line
is equalizing pretty much
oh oh happy birthday tagi wait it's
actually oh it's your birthday i thought
you just randomly
were picking a day for me to play geo
well everyone wish toggy happy birthday
maybe i'll have to include this on the
youtube
in the youtube video if you made it this
far
i guess when i post this on youtube it
won't be your birthday anymore
but youtube people can wish tagi a
belated
happy birthday